Geeked Week
Welcome to GEEKED Week! GEEKED Week!
Netflix Geek Week.
2022 is all about getting you
the latest news trailers and all kinds of
first looks for your favorite Netflix
shows, films, games and more.
I'm Jay Stoobs.
And I'm Jacob Scott Thomas Bertrand.
And I mean also the all valley champ.
Oh you can't forget it
put some respect on my name that's right.
And today is all about series
and we have a lot to cover.
So much we're dropping new titles,
fresh trailers and checking in
with some of our favorite stars.
It is going to be a wild, wild week
and we are beyond stoked
for all the surprises in store.
There's tons of horror,
which is totally my
jam, and Jacob is going to get through it.
Yeah, like nightmares are hard.
I guess they're.
Like your Guillermo del Toro's
cabinet of curiosities, school
tales, the series
and all things Mike Flanagan.
I mean, what about the final season
of Lock and Key?
And I cannot wait for Shadow and Bone.
Oh, and Resident Evil.
So many great shows, so little time.
So let's dove
into our first reveal of the day.
Yeah, we promised you surprises.
And here we have a very first
look at one of the most highly anticipated
new shows coming in. 2022.
Let's see it.
That's all we get?
Oh my goodness I want more.
Yeah, I know that was barely anything,
but it was still so much.
I'm gonna have the snaps
when I wake up in the morning.
That was our first look at Wednesday,
the new Netflix series
Bringing to life the twisted world
of the Addams Family in a whole new way.
Yeah.
I mean, who doesn't love Wednesday?
She is a style icon.
I got to say. Yeah.
I mean, I know I personally
try to emulate her style every single day.
Jenna Ortega plays the title role
along with her disembodied
ally thing, and oh my God,
this girl is the queen of horror.
Right? Yeah, she's killing it.
In this new show, for the first time
ever, Wednesday is a teenager
at the Gothic Nevermore Academy.
She gets pulled into a murder mystery
that has major implications
for her entire family.
Wednesday features a stellar creative
team, also led by co-creators Myles Miller
and Al Gough of Smallville.
And director Tim Burton.
The man. The myth, the legend, himself.
That is so cool!
For more of the latest news on Wednesday.
Be sure to follow Wednesday,
Netflix on Instagram Wednesday.
We want a major moment
to open Geeked Week with.
And we're just getting started.
But I mean,
what could possibly follow that?
I know it seems impossible that we can
have something even more exciting, but
Guillermo del Toro.
Really.
Yeah. That's pretty sick.
Guillermo del
Toro is one of the most prolific voices
of the horror genre,
a legend of the supernatural.
And he's creating a brand new series
for Netflix, spotlighting
some of the most creative and innovative
minds working in horror today.
His new show, Guillermo del Toro's
Cabinet of Curiosities, features
an all star lineup of amazing talent,
both in front of the camera
and behind the camera.
To know what to expect, let's open
that metaphorical cabinet and find out.
That was so eerie.
Holy shit, I am.
Oh, I am going to need a minute to recover
from that
literally.
First of all,
we need more horror anthology shows.
I that is my personal jame, but
also the directors of Mandy the Babadook.
Holy cow.
That's pretty nuts.
Oh, they had me at Guillermo del Toro.
Now I'm going to be counting the days.
I don't know.
If I'm ready for all these nightmares.
I'll send you some tips.
I've been doin this for a while.
Spanos Cosmatos ,Jennifer Kent.
Catherine Hardwicke-del
Toro has entrusted some top shelf
horror directors
with their own interpretations
of some of his personal favorite horror
stories. I don't.
I can't imagine anything better than this.
Yeah, it's insane.
I mean, they're joined by a talented, star
studded cast
to bring all these stories to life.
Ben Barnes, Rupert Grint, Sofia Boutella.
Not to mention Andrew
Lincoln, Crispin Glover and Essea Davis
all in one anthology series.
Is this allowed?
It's literally too good.
I'm going to have a panic attack.
It's so good to see his creepy,
beautiful brand of horror
continuing to take over Netflix.
OK, speaking of creepy,
you want to hear a scary story?
It's like 9 a.m.
Just trying to push you.
I knew a lot going on lately.
Let me teach you the ways of the horror
of losing it's close
to midnight, somewhere close to Tokyo.
It's the perfect
time to talk about the Midnight Club,
which is Mike Flanagans new horror show.
Oh, yeah?
You mean Mike Flanagan the creator of The
Haunting of Hill House and Midnight Mass.
That Mike!
And we have an exclusive first look
from another familiar face, Rahul Kohli.
Oh, let's check it out.
All right, everyone, I'm
Rahul Kohli,
and you may have seen me in some shows.
Like Midnight Mass
and The Haunting of Bly Manor.
But the thing I probably get recognized
for the most
is probably last year's
host of Geeked week.
But unfortunately,
I can't be there with you guys this year
because I'm currently filming a new show
with my good pal, Mr.
Mike Flanagan.
We are currently in production for
the fall of the House of Usher for Netflix
I can't
really give you any details
and it's not ready,
but I do have something else
that I could tease for Mr.
Flanagan.
So picture this, OK, a group of teens
gather around nightly to share
ghostly horror stories in like a shape
shifting mansion.
With a kind of, like, bloody history.
All right.
I probably didn't sell it that well,
but what I can do is now give you
the first look at the Midnight Club
from the Master of Horror himself, Mr.
Mike Flanagan.
To those before
To those after
to us now
and to those beyond.
Seen or unseen
here.
But not here.
Seen or unseen.
Here but not here.
Your face!
Your eye.
I can't help it.
Like the kids are evil.
Or the house is evil.
I don't know what's going on!
I mean, I.
That looks so creepy,
first of all, that cast looks amazing.
I I'm very intrigued. I love spooky teens.
That's, like, a thing that's like a genre
that we absolutely like.
We need more in the spooky teens.
You need more teens.
They kind of freak me out.
Like, just regular teens, I would think,
you know, youths, but especially
when they start, you know, hosting
midnight vigils and stuff, I'm like.
It was so good to see Rahul again.
Rahul hosted the show
last year and, you know,
so waiting for my Street Fighter rematch.
Uh oh. Yes.
I still think he cheated.
I mean, think they had
some backstage stuff going on.
I believe in you. I'm rooting for you.
Come on, let's go.
Haha.
The new cast in that teaser looked killer.
Maybe even literally.
I really hope not.
Mike Flanagan always puts together
an exceptional cast, the Midnight Club
reuniting with some of his most frequent
acting collaborators,
which includes Samantha Sloyan
and Zach Gilford and Annarah Cymone.
Plus Igby Rigney, Matt Biedel and,
of course, Rahul Kohli.
It also stars some new Flanagan faces
like Iman Benson.
Ruth Codd and Aya Furukawa.
Also Adia Sauriyan Sapkota
And William Chris Sumpter
as the titular midnight club.
Based off the novel of the same name
by Christopher Pike.
Mike Flannigan's, The Midnight Club
is coming to Netflix soon.
Speaking of scary stories, this next
one is chilling and I am already afraid.
You need to take some deep breaths.
Horror is your thing. Yeah.
It really gets me.
It knows how to make me scared.
Coming from Thailand.
School Tales is an eight
episode horror series inspired by eight
horrifying comic stories.
During the day.
The school belongs to the students,
but at night
it's unfortunately a different story.
Isn't that always the case?
Today we have three first book clips
from three different episodes.
Let's take a look at the first one
from the episode titled
A Walk in School,
which already scary to me.
Hello. It's me, Boy.
Today I'm taking you all on a mission
to debunk the old beliefs
that ghosts are real
and that there are ghosts in every school.
The first stop I'm taking
you guys to is a traditional dance club.
Today I'm with a friend.
This is Tum.
He's one of the people who still believes
in ghost stories
despite all the scientific
theories that have debunked them.
Today
Tum and
I will take you
all with us to prove
those old tales are all lies.
Are you ready Tum?
Yeah he's ready.
I don't know I'm with Tum.
I feel so bad for Tum.
you know I identify with Tum!
I got to say I as a lover of horror
I'm not spending any nights
in a supposedly haunted school.
Gosh, the title is so misleading.
A walk in school.
It felt like a safe space.
Sounded like a Raold Dahl novel--but
you get murdered in the end!
You know--
In walking school, two students announced
that they will host a live broadcast
to expose that all the frightening tales
are just lies which and why.
But their quest pushes the boys
deeper and deeper into the unknown.
In each story, the opening leads them
further into the abyss of hell.
Poor Tum! That's not ambiguous at all.
It our
next clip is from the episode
Vengeful Spell, where the discovery
of a murdered student
reveals a more sinister secret, which I'm.
Will high schoolers ever learn
to stop seeking out angry spirits?
You know, I got to be honest.
I don't I don't want them to.
Who are we kidding?
OK, like, let's let's let's take a look.
If you want to curse
someone write their name under your foot
and chant this ground stomping spell.
"Ohm jakka jakka, winas mouranang,
jakka jakka namapata ou ou."
That took such a weird turn.
I was not expecting that.
I got to say, I cut somebody off
in traffic the other day,
and I curses really freaked me out, man.
You never know.
Oh, my God.
Is it that easy,
do you think? I mean, I you're right.
Someone your foot, I guess.
I mean, I certainly I don't know what
I don't know what I would say in English.
I curse you?
I think you've got to believe it.
Mean it hard enough. Yeah, I guess.
Well, I mean, the last clip we have
today is from an episode called Lunch.
Oh, good.
Yeah, actually, I am kind of hungry.
So perfect timing.
Yeah.
I don't think you're going to want to eat
after you learn the secret ingredient
Aunt Jong is using
to make her rice and curry so delicious.
So let's see.
Maybe we'll be hungry.
Kid, what are you doing in my stall?
Please leave.
Ma'am, here's the thing.
I'm live-streaming to show
how delicious your food is.
I won't take much time.
Can I see what's in this pot? Kid, don't.
Don't do this. Please leave kid.
Wow. You're acting suspicious.
Hey everyone. Look. You're acting way too
suspicious ma'am.
That means there must be
something in the pot.
Otherwise you would not be so secretive
about it.
Out of my way ma'am. Move!
What bones are those? HEY! Shit.
Ouch!
I don't think I want to know
what's in that pot.
Why does he want to know you is so bad?
He's being a little rude to the ma'am.
Here's what I'm picking up from this is
that you can never trust a live streamer
because this is
this seems to be a reoccurring.
Yes, but see, look at
look at all the cameras!
Live streaming.
I'm telling you, don't trust them!
No way. I'm never live
streaming ever again.
This horror anthology from Five Star
Productions is coming soon enough,
so stay tuned for more information.
And now it's time for another new series.
We have a first look at a new sci
fi drama, The Imperfects, where
20 somethings get turned into monsters
by evil scientists against their wills.
The cast recorded us a special message
to set up an exciting surprise.
So let's take a look.
Hello, everyone.
Hey, guys. Hello, everyone. Hi.
My name is Rihanna Jagpal and I play Abbey
Sing I play Dr. Sydney Burke. And I play
Tilda.
And I play Juan Ruiz in the upcoming
Netflix series "The Imperfects."
Some things I have in common with Tilda.
Singing is also my medicine.
However,
I'm more of a shower singer than that.
Abby is a brilliant scientist,
and I think that her and I are very
similar in the sense that there is nothing
that can get in the way of us
helping the people that we love.
I relate to Sidney in the perfectionist
kind of way where everything has its place
and is needed is organized.
Yeah, she's pretty meticulous,
and I think some of my stuff.
What do I relate to with Juan?
Well, we're both very talented drawers.
We're both very, extremely handsome.
He's from Mexico (I am also from Mexico)
and we both have a very,
very terrifying
monster inside us that we can't control.
Well, that's too much information anyways.
Fans can expect a lot from this show.
There's so many surprises and twists
and turns.
Every episode opens with a bang.
It has suspense,
It has monsters, It has evil scientists!
Unexpected love interests
And good old fashioned sexual tension.
I'm very,
very excited for people to see this show.
It's a whole fun, fantastic World
where You just kind of
get to lose yourself and have a good time.
Season
one Of the Imperfects Don't miss it.
You're going to love this.
Do you remember Dr.
Sarkar?
They experimented on us
without our perfmission.
We all had
adverse reactions.
We're not even human anymore.
Technically, no
Well, that's fucking great.
If we're not human, what are we
You're.
That looks frickin sick~ Sick.
Yeah, that's.
That's definitely got my interest piqued.
Yeah.
The shot of the
where the werewolf thing with the spider.
Yeah! Frickin Awesome!
I mean, I love a story about suppressing
a monster in your twenties.
I feel like that's
widely relatable.
Yeah, I would say and Inaki dude,
that guy is killing it.
I can't wait.
The whole cast looks crazy. Impressive.
I can't
wait to see what they've got up to.
I just.
I mean, yeah, the premise.
The premise is, is killer Yeah.
I'm sorry I'm not stopping these puns tho.
Maybe.
Maybe I'm
going to call this a soft promise.
We also have some exclusive posters
from the imperfects
showing each of the characters.
Check this one out.
Oh, yeah.
She looks very cool. All three of them.
There's a rock star, too.
I like a good rockstar.
The rockstar is good.
Everybody is artsy in this is artsy too.
Oh. Poor kid.
I feel like he's just so confused
going through all this.
Really does it
like he's a werewolf, doesn't know it.
Figuring it out.
Wakes up naked in the woods.
And covered in blood.
Your twenties are hard.
Hard, you know? Hey.
Why can't we just normalize that?
All right?
Twenties are hard.
I already know
this is going to be my favorite character.
Just like
"are you fucking kidding me?"
She just seems cool.
Look, she looks really tough.
Yeah, these are definitely not
the college cliques that I'm used to.
The Imperfects has an all star
lineup of Inaki Godoy,
Morgan Taylor Campbell,
Rihanna Jagpal and Italia Ricci.
Be sure to check out this brand new series
only on Netflix.
Maybe we should.
Or can we move on to something
a little sweeter?
You know, horror and scaring me
constantly.
Yeah really. You've done so well so far.
But, hey, I mean, that's a good idea.
Did you see season one of Sweet Tooth?
I did. I loved it.
I can't wait for season two as well.
Oh, my God. Me too.
What kind of hybrid do you think you'd be?
I obviously have to be a hawk.
Considering all of the wordplay
that I've been getting into.
Yeah, that's my bad. That's my bad.
Is anyone out there like me?
I need to find them
I will yes.
So wholesome, man, that kid really is
the cutest.
He is so adorable.
Well, season two of Sweet Tooth
was announced in 2021, and the cast
has been hard at work bringing to life
all the latest adventures of Gus.
Jacob you mentioned
you're really excited about season two.
And lucky for you, we actually have
a very special update from the cast
in shooting in New Zealand.
This is a story,
a story of a very special group of people
who found themselves at the end
of filming season two of Sweet Tooth.
Everybody that was a wrap
for season 2!
Season two of Sweet Tooth.
Yeah, it's been a long journey
and it's been very hard work,
but it's been amazing fun and I can't wait
to share with you what happens.
In season two.
The stakes are higher,
the battles are bigger.
The mean guys are meaner.
In for a treat.
There's going to be an amazing. Adventure.
But this isn't the end of their story,
and I can't wait to see what happens next.
Bye bye.
Aw man, the mean guys are meaner?
How long have you had that candy bar?
I literally just said I was hungry,
but I mean,
if you haven't seen every tooth,
you're missing out.
It's the most uplifting show
about the apocalypse I've ever seen.
So wholesome.
It is. It's amazing.
And the incredible series
is based on the DC
comic book series of the same name
by Jeff Lemire
and produced by Robert Downey
Junior and Susan Downey.
At the end of Season one.
We were wondering
if you Amy would save the hybrids.
Yeah.
And when he'll be reunited with his mom.
Which we have to know, but we have to wait
until season two to find out.
But you can catch season one right now.
And be sure to follow SweetToothNetflix
and NetflixGeeked
for all the season two updates.
This is a good bar.
Give me some of that. Sorry.
So uh,
look what I Just found in my pocket.
Whoa!
What is that mysterious object?
Conveniently place in your pocket?
I know-some kind of key.
Think you understand about those keys?
You don't.
I don't think the masses understands,
but I think I do.
This is the key to unlock the season
three teaser trailer for Lock and Key.
Oh, my God.
Are you serious? It's going to work.
Absolutely.
It's the third and final season. Believe
that this is exactly how you do it.
I know it's going to work.
Nothing makes more sense than this.
If I do it a million times, it's
going to play the teaser.
Just keep going.
Yeah, I almost got it.
We're going to unlock
the teaser and find out. OK.
Past is always workers.
Try and run away
from.
It's always there
We've been tangled up in that for years.
Especially if you're trapped
and something more
This is our house.
Those keys belong to us.
Oh, that looks so.
Ominous. I'm so invested.
What was that
screaming in front of the angel wings.
Yeah. I mean. What the heck was that?
I mean, I'm more invested in
what's going on with.
With the. Well, lady,
I really want to know.
Feel like what is going on?
I'm just. I'm so curious.
I mean, to have this kind of power
at your fingertips is so crazy.
I want to know what it all means.
Yeah. What it leads to. Yeah.
And what's the significance of, like,
your house is to the family?
I just. I'm
so I'm. I'm invested. Very invested.
I can't wait to see more Jackson.
But, you know,
it's from the showrunners, Carlton Cuse
and Meredith Avril Lock and Key
is an adaptation of the bestselling
comic book series by Joe Hill
and Gabriel Rodriguez.
Season two ended with a pretty massive
cliffhanger, a new threat
and the most dangerous yet
looms in Matheson.
In the upcoming season,
the Locke Family will uncover more magic
within Key House to take on this
new threat, an epic final battle.
And you will not want to miss it.
And I think I speak for all the fans
when I say we are sad to see it end,
but can't wait to find out what happens.
The fandom has been guessing and hoping
and predicting all kinds of outcomes
for the series.
I've been all over social media.
Don't miss the final season of Lock
and Key when it premieres on Netflix
on August 10th.
Wow. We actually get a date
that's pretty sick.
Oh, we're getting.
We're getting fed today. Yeah.
And not just from
whatever is in Aunt Jong's pot.
Exactly.
Next up, we have a series that's making
a triumphant return for a second season.
At a medical boarding school where
magical teens hone their magical skills.
Magical problems always seem to come up
funny how that happens.
I love magical boarding schools.
And we're talking
about fate, the Winx saga.
We always knew your path
wouldn't be like everyone else's
but about wait to see who you will come.
Pretty cool.
Fire eyes. It's getting me.
Inspired.
Inspired by the beloved animated show
Faith, the Winx saga follows Bloom,
a ferry with fire powers, which is kind of
arguably the best kind of power.
Oh, this is pretty sick.
Yeah.
When she enrolls
in a magical boarding school at Alfayate.
Yeah.
With the help of her new fairy friends,
Stella, Aisha, Tara and Ussa Season one,
she's been learning
more about her past while the team
faces off against terrifying threats
of the burned ones.
For somebody with fire powers, how do you.
I was like, wow,
this might not be the best thing ever.
She's fighting burned people.
Seems like they already got the fire.
I mean.
I feel like she's maybe.
How do you overcome that?
Maybe she could get, like, a buddy
with some water powers and steam.
And ice.
Like, hot,
steamy, spiraled into in and death.
And we've got a fan favorite
that's finally joining the cast of Fate.
The Winx Saga and season two,
Flora played by Paulina Chavez.
Fate fans, you're in luck
because we're able to reveal the first
look at the Earth
fairy flora in the season two.
Helder en route.
I'm pretty sure he's tried it.
Can you remember what the bite
some body look like?
Multiple incisions,
a pattern might narrow it down.
It doesn't matter.
This is a useless exercise.
That already said he's
not going to let you help.
Well, I'm very convincing.
More so than Rosalind.
Because she was very clear
no students were allowed near Devon.
Dad won't do anything
she doesn't approve of.
Pathetic as that is.
You need to lay off them, and you.
Need to get back to the school grounds.
It's dangerous out there.
I'll be done when I'm done.
Whoever you are,
I come up very, very slowly.
Flora!
Miss me?
That was so wholesome.
That was such a beautiful moment
of friendship. I love it.
You almost don't realize how terrifying
those, like, poison ivy powers are.
What?
I thought I was going to get attacked
by vines.
I know. I started
growing beautiful flowers.
With the whole other direction.
Looks like there's a new arrival to Alfea.
Yeah, she's very floral,
and fans are pumped to see Flora
join the fun in season
two and Paulina nails this role.
Floral joined Bloom, Stella, Aisha, Tara
and Musa in season two as they fight
to save Alfea from a new evil threat
that threatens the inhabitants.
Why can't they just catch a break, man?
I know.
Why can't they just hang out, burn
some stuff.
Give each other hugs.
To grow back with the earth. Fairies?
In between the burnings.
But you don't have to wait too long
to find out what happens next.
We have exciting news that season two
is coming to Netflix in fall.
2022. That's really soon.
It's going to be hard to prioritize
this which the watch yeah
everything is coming out so quickly.
I'm really excited about.
This this one
is going to be your number one priority.
Come on! Come on! Give it to me!
Warrior Nun fans
yeah you asking and asking and asking.
I think Jacob's personally been harassing
the Netflix team
asking for any tease of season two.
Fortunately, the wait is over.
I love in action sequences
when they speed up the hits.
Yes. Do do do do do.
Oh that's so sick.
Well,
if you're into a creepy mythology, bad
ass superpowers and intense
fight scenes between nuns.
Yeah, I wouldn't love that
this series is definitely made for you.
I'm so.
Sorry.
Warrior Nun follows an orphaned
teen named Eva who wakes up in a morgue.
I mean, like, universal experience
with a new lease on life
and a divine artifact
embedded in her back and discovers
she possesses superpowers
as the chosen halo bearer
for a secret sect of demon hunting nuts.
The best type of nun.
I wonder where that secret sect practices,
and if I could go to them.
I want to find, like,
that section of Catholic history.
Yes, that would be like.
I want to know what Codex?
They got this. Yeah.
We have a first
look at season two, so let's check it out.
I know.
You want to know what happened to tell you
the truth.
I'm still figuring it out myself.
First I was dead, then I was alive.
Then I got tricked.
And then the devil kicked my ass
still,
there's a thousand
items left in my life to do list,
but you can't check them off
if you're dead.
No one in history
has ever defeated a trio and left.
It looks like
we're going to have to make history
I told you that
I would learn to swim.
Thank you. Warrior Nun.
You know, I don't.
I'm just saying, Jesus walked on water.
She was fully sprinting. Just sprinting.
I didn't know that.
That's what it was like to be a nun.
I would have been a lot more interested.
Yeah damn,
I would have joined a long time ago.
Where's the sign up sheet?
I feel like we really missed out the pitch
that was given to me was very different.
But everyone's
favorite demon fighting
nuns are back in season two of Warrior.
Now, for more action and updates,
check out Netflix Geek on Instagram.
I can't believe how many first looks
and big reveals
we've already shown you today
and we're just getting started here.
We're very lucky very lucky people.
Later today.
We've got everyone's favorite,
of course, the Bradleys
together to debut an exclusive clip
from the Umbrella Academy
Season three premiere and preview
what we have to look forward to.
I'm so excited for this. Yes.
And we will also finally finally, finally
going to find out
when The Sandman is premiering on Netflix,
when Neil Gaiman,
Tom Sturridge and the cast
sit down with sleazy day
to talk about the long awaited adaptation
that will be.
I'm so excited.
But first, we're not done just yet.
It's time for Jacob, Shadow and Bone.
Hack. Yeah. Did you watch Season one?
I mean, I did,
and it was a global sensation, and I'm
still fighting with people online
about whether I'm Team Darklina or Malina.
I mean, we do need to get you off Tumblr.
We have talked about that.
During last year's geek week,
we announced that Shadow and Bone
will be coming back for season two.
And since then, we've gotten some long
awaited casting news
that Jack Wolf
will be playing the final Crow: Wylan.
And Patrick
Gibson is playing the heartthrob Nikolai.
And Badasses Analia Brophy and Louis
Tan are playing the dynamic duo
Tamara and Tolya.
But I mean fans, we the fans.
We want another update.
We need one.
And well, Jay Stoobs here in luck
because we have a very special video
from the cast.
Hello Grishaverse.
In honor of Netflix's Geeks Week,
we thought we would share some exciting
news of the year.
We've officially wrapped Season
two Shadow in Bone,
and we cannot wait for you to see what
we've been up to.
Really sad that it's over it
also very excited for you guys to see it.
Oh, we can't give too much away
at this time.
We wanted to answer a few questions to
keep you guys guessing on what's to come
loves power, heartbreak,
heart rending,
heart pounding Swashbuckling
full of
life.
Bigger, bolder, badder, action packed,
epic and contested.
It's it's just kind of been
hashtag guilty.
underestimated, angry Fierce.
Traumatized, but also the best
come on.
It's not even a question.
Come on.
Just just kill us with pistols, please.
I'm going to have to go with Tim's axes.
Sorry, Jasper. Come on, guys.
That's a no brainer.
Is access all the way?
Come on. You're speaking to a crow.
Crow club all the way.
I'm just in a crow club.
Definitely the Crow Club.
Drinking, gambling.
It's great year in Hell Gate all day long.
I think I do. All right.
And then make a few friends for sure.
You know, there's things you'll see
in Hellgate that you can't unsee.
Trent cheering there.
Spider waffles. 100%.
It's gonna be pancakes,
pancakes a lovely vegan crepe
We are all
so excited and
we cannot wait for you to see season two.
Happy Geeked Week, and we'll see you
on the other side of the fold.
That's a wrap.
I just wish I had a British accent.
Wow. I wish I was a part of it.
It's so sweet.
Oh, my God. It was like,
cross the border, spend the year.
It was like pancakes, and waffles?
but I love it.
Based on the hit novels by Leigh Bardugo
Shadow and Bone has an all star cast.
Oh, Jesse Mei Li Ben Barnes,
Archie Renaud.
As well as Freddy Carter.
Amita Suman, Kit Young.
Kanjeh Polaroid when?
I mean be sure to follow Shadow
and Bone on Instagram and Netflix geeked
for all this season 2 updates.
Are you ready to introduce the next show?
You do need a breather
because it's a big one. Yes.
I have recovered from my Shadow
and bone fandom.
I am more than excited to introduce
the first look at season four of Manifest.
Yes, and we were so stoked
when Netflix announced
that Manifest will be coming back
for its fourth and final season.
Fans can't wait to find out what actually
happened to the passengers on Flight 828.
And we now have a special message
from Josh Dallas.
So take it away. Josh.
Hey, it's Josh.
We're working hard here
filming the final season of Manifest.
There is a two part
final season coming soon to Netflix.
But in the meantime, here's a clip coming
your way.
Cherry Blossoms, there you are.
I mean, it's something.
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, I'm more preoccupied
with the baggage carved into his arm.
Yeah.
Definitely the same.
I mean, I don't know about you, but when
I, you know, do my investigating yeah.
Yeah.
Getting into, you know, the docs,
the last thing I expect
is an arm to reach out to me.
A shipping container.
I'm just so curious, like,
how long that thing's been there.
Exactly why call it that?
You can have carved that
on the side of the wall.
I'm like,
this guy went all in on it on his arm.
That's intense. Must be important.
The Shining light
coming out of the shipping container.
What's going. On there? And dark inside?
I don't know. Yeah, she's out there
trying to hoodwink us. Exactly.
Yeah, there's something. You know what?
I'm going to go ahead and call it now.
We're smarter than that.
Something amiss is happening here.
Yeah, there is something amiss.
We figured it out.
There's. There's a mystery here.
You heard it here first, so get ready
for the epic conclusion of Manifest
by rewatching seasons one, two, three.
Maybe that maybe your answer
is there. Yeah, and what's on the air.
But up next, we have something
a little more nice for you to tweet
from our friends at Vikings Valhalla.
You are here because you are vikings!
Oh, yeah.
That is badass. Wow.
That was that's really sick.
That was quite violent. I like that.
I guess
it it's pretty pretty pretty bad ass.
I'm having Hawk flashbacks.
I like it. I'm feeling invigorated.
That is what it reminded me of.
I wish I wish
my signs were changing a lot.
Right now,
the evolution of the original series
Vikings was a massive hit when it dropped
on Netflix earlier this year, and already
a second season has been announced.
While we can't show you what's in store
for Leif and Herald in Season
two just yet, we do have a Season
one blooper reel to help tide you over.
I love Bloopers. Also excited.
Let's check out some of the laughs
behind the making of Vikings Valhalla.
Go, go, Vikings.
We heard that it was geeked week.
We before we set off to battle
towards our next season.
We wanted to stop in and say thank you.
Thank you so much.
You helped us to become a Top Ten series
in 91 countries,
which my brain can't even comprehend.
And we are so excited to be able
to bring you
not one but two more seasons of Vikings
Scott Thomas.
As a thank you.
Yeah, we wanted to share with you some top
secret info about the next season.
Firstly, there's not going to be any
fighting, no axes no swords, no arrows.
We're done with that.
Secondly, no more romance with can they?
They said it will wasn't taking.
And finally, pagans and the Christians
will become the greatest friends
and there will be peace
everywhere.
Now, all jokes
aside, a Viking wouldn't
come to Gateway without a gift.
So we offer up the greatest gift to.
Be a video of us make complete
and utter full summer selves.
Please enjoy for the first time ever
a glorious reel
of Vikings Valhalla Bloopers.
That they say they did say action. Yes.
Come at me.
Sense of God.
no I mean do that again.
Do that again. I'm going to do that again.
But I believe I could be of service
to you here in England.
Should you a crab should you
actually like to start?
I'd love to start again and do that again.
Wrong line. Of
because my hair OK like this OK.
Yeah, it is now.
Is now.
Just the bacon.
I slept here
right here.
And this.
That's great.
I've always thought the best way to
approach to getting on a horse is to just.
Yeah, just like what is just,
like, dead fish onto it
for the horse. Would love that.
Well.
All right.
Looks like the cast had an amazing time.
You just flopped sideways on the water.
Jacob's got some tips there.
Yes. Yeah, there we go.
Well, hey, if you like Vikings
and you can't get enough of period action
adventure shows,
then you're going to really enjoy
this next sword and sandal series.
That's a good sword and sandal.
Yeah. I think it's a good genre. Yeah.
This isn't written.
I just came up with I am prolific.
Of course, talking about barbarians.
Nothing lasts forever.
(singing)
There's
just there's just something about dudes
angry, screaming
in the shower with their arms out.
You know? I mean, it speaks to me.
I don't know.
It's like it's vicarious, you know,
we live in such a world where, like,
if you get frustrated with someone,
the best you can do is just be like,
oh, OK. Like,
a little passive aggression in your day.
But apparently
there used to be other option.
You know what?
The next time you're at Starbucks,
you should try that. Jay.
Yeah.
My battle ax and start screaming.
Yeah, exactly.
We'll Barbarians is about a Roman officer
torn between the mighty empire
that raised him and his own tribal people,
which leads to an epic
historical clash season.
One ended with a massive battle
of the Romans ambushing the barbarians.
And I mean, what's going to happen next?
We have a sneak peek at season two.
There is only Rome.
Only the Roman army can do that.
We show our people
that Rome is not invincible.
We will fight.
I was like, the Romans are going to fall.
I mean, spoiler alert,
but the Romans did not meet their
needs.
Things don't end well for the Romans.
But I do love to see a woman
pulling an ax.
I'm not going to lie.
You heard it here first on Geeked Week
Folks Barbarian Season two
is finally coming to Netflix this fall.
This fall, everything's this fall.
I know it's crazy.
We can check out season one now on Netflix
if you haven't already.
And if you have,
I mean, why not just rewatch.
It and prepare for the fall? Yeah.
Up next, we have a series.
This become a global sensation.
Based on the web.
You now at our school,
we have all of us are dead.
I love zombies.
All of us are dead.
It's a coming of age story
set in catastrophic circumstances
where a group of loyal friends
band together to overcome zombies
and crushes and bullies.
Cast got together for a special message
to help us celebrate some of the big news.
All of US Are Dead
is coming back for season two.
Is this on?
Can you see me?
Hi everyone long time no see.
Thank you to all our fans
who love All of Us Are Dead season 1.
How have you all been?
We've been well.
And have you heard the good news?
All of us are dead
will be returning for season 2!
What sort of events
will take place in
All of Us Are Dead season 2?
Oh no,
I will.
Regardless of how into zombies you are,
I think it's safe to say
that all of us are here
for all of us are dead.
All right, everybody, our time with you
is coming towards an end.
So you know what's coming up next.
It's got to be good.
But don't go anywhere.
Even though Jacob and I may soon
be saying our farewell, Felicia Day
is going to be sitting down with the cast
of the Umbrella Academy and the Sandman
and revealing some exciting exclusives
from the upcoming series.
Meanwhile, our friends at most
got together with the cast of First Kill
and put on a vampire ball.
How do I get invited to that?
I need to go to
a vampire will. Be a vampire.
Here.
I missed the first requirement, OK?
And that's just day one of geek week.
We have four more days and big reveals
cast reunions and Stranger Things.
(sings stranger things theme)
We got to get you as a sound guy I.
Really good I could totally.
You're a one man Foley artist.
Come on Netflix hook it up.
OK but we have promised some big news
before we sign off.
Yes and for those of you who have been up
in the Netflix geeked comments demanding
more news on Alice and Borderland
your time is now.
What's been two long years since Alice
in Borderland first shopped on Netflix
and in the time since it's
ranked in the top ten in over 70 countries
twice the second time after the release
of the mega-hit Screen Game.
And the upcoming season
is sure to be incredible.
For those of you who aren't familiar,
let's take a look back at season one.
Isn't
this Strange?
Shall we go? The game will now begin.
The genre of each
game is decided by the card's suit.
The game will now begin. Clubs, a team
battle. Diamonds, a battle of wits.
Which switch turns on the light bulb?
Hearts a game of betrayal that messes
with your emotions. Clear the game.
Then we can go home?
I can see
clearly now.
The game will now begin.
You need to survive.
To get something you must lose something.
What are you thinking?
Our lives
have limits.
Do you want to live?
We're still alive
Oh my god.
Looks so good, so intense.
If you haven't watched it yet.
Alice in Borderland is a Japanese sci
fi thriller about gamers
who end up in a parallel world
where they have to play for survival.
And the upcoming season
is sure to be incredible.
Just take a look
at these images of the stars.
Kento Yamazaki and
Tao Tsuchiya I mean, they don't
they don't look thrilled.
It's so dire.
So dire.
Kento Yamazaki
as the video game obsessed Ryohei Arisu
So I feel like he's looking at the game
master.
Oh, you think it's a big reveal here.
And Tao Tsyuchia as the mountain
climbing obsessed Yuzuha Usagi Battle
to get one final winner.
That's the winner right there.
If you love Squid Game
Kingdom or Hell Bound,
you're sure to love Alice in Borerland.
Hey, Jacob, by the way,
are you a fan of one piece?
Come on, now.
Come on, give it to me.
I had a feeling one
piece is one of the biggest manga I got.
That has been Give Me Some Lessons
and anime of all time.
I can't believe it has over 1000 episodes.
That is pretty nuts. And Movies.
The quest to Be The Pirate King is coming
to live action in the new Netflix series
starring in Inaki Godoy, Emily Rudd,
can you Jacob Gibson and Tess Skyler.
The cast has been hard
at work in South Africa,
bringing the world of one piece to life.
And to get a sense of the show,
we got an exclusive behind the scenes
look at a truly massive set.
So let's roll the clip.
Hello, everyone.
I'm Inaki and I play Loofee in one piece.
I am Steve Mara.
I'm the showrunner of one piece,
I'm Matt Owens, showrunner.
And as you can see,
we're here in South Africa bringing.
One piece. To life.
We'd like to show you a sneak
peek of some of our massive sets.
The biggest one piece
fan. It's a really exciting scene.
Some of my favorite places from the market
become a reality.
All right, enough talk.
Roll the clip.
Robert
Otis world is so unique.
Seen all of this stuff in person.
Being able to reach out and touch
it is just been such an experience.
Our crews down here in South
Africa are incredible
and it's been so rewarding to see them
taking Otis World and bringing it to life.
Because
of the level of detail of attention
that goes into all of these sets.
They take a good amount of time.
I mean, right now we're building Arlung's
map room, and it's already been
a couple of weeks, but it's a big build
because it's a really important location.
A lot of drama goes down in there.
A lot of action goes down in there.
So we have to get it just right.
I love all the ships,
but Bartier is massive.
It is iconic.
It is surrounded by floating docks
along with a bar inside the fish mouth,
which is going to be Zora's
favorite spot in those episodes.
At the end of it all, I'm most excited
to just be able to share this world
with old fans.
And we got to go to work every day
and walk on these massive sets
and see these characters come to life.
It's a really special
experience and a privilege,
and we can't wait to share it with you.
Oh, man,
I can't believe they built all of that.
I mean, to see those sets and live action,
it's just it's got to be so exciting
for a long time. One piece fans.
That was our first look at the Baratier.
That's so cool.
I mean, the attention to detail,
everything we saw,
so intricate and so incredible Yeah.
And we actually have some exciting
casting news for one piece.
Chiomo Umuela will play Noriko,
Celeste Loots will be Katya.
And Alexander Maniatis will be Clawdor
And will have Langley Kirkwood
as Captain Morgan.
Plus Craig Fairbrass
as Chef Zeff and Steven Ward as Mahogany.
You can't wait to hit the high seas
be sure to follow one piece, Netflix
and Netflix
Geeked on Instagram and Twitter.
But don't set sail just yet
because our next title is something
you're not going to want to miss.
Yeah. Coming July 14th, Evil has evolved.
That's right.
We're talking about Resident Evil.
The legendary franchise
redefined for Netflix set.
14 years after a deadly virus
caused a global apocalypse.
As that happens, Resident Evil sees Jade
Wesker, the daughter of Albert Wesker,
fighting for survival in a world overrun
by the bloodthirsty infected.
She's haunted by her past in new Raccoon
city and her father's chilling
connections to the Umbrella Corporation.
But most importantly,
what happened to her sister.
Wait what happened to her sister?
Well, there we'll see, because right here
we're getting the very first
trailer for Resident Evil.
They said the world would end in 2036.
But they were wrong.
The world ended a long time ago.
Umbrella, a company besieged by scandal,
is now trying to reinvent itself.
So blame the old umbrella.
Make mistakes.
The things we're working on
today are going to change the world.
Where it's safe
we have a problem.
The drug contains the virus.
The virus can make monsters.
Billions will die.
Everyone keep your mouth shut.
Fuck it.
It's complicated.
It's the old timey music
that makes everything really eerie.
Why does always make it so creepy?
Yeah, it's such a good juxtaposition,
really.
Is. But, like, Resident Evil had such a
hold on, like when I was in high school.
Oh, my God.
I can feel like 2000s ish is like when,
like, Milla Jovivich just owned the world.
But I got to say, like,
the property always had so much potential,
and I just feel like, oh, my God,
like this.
This looks like the best possible version
of this story.
I'm so excited.
Lance Reddick leads
the cast as Albert Wesker
and is joined by Ella Balinska
and Tamara Smart.
It also stars Pauola Nunez.
Siena Agudong and Adeline Rudolph.
It's seriously just gives us the best
of what Resident Evil has to offer.
A badass heroes, insane creatures,
a fight for survival and a deep mystery
to unravel.
and you know how we love mystery.
We can also reveal this creepy new poster
for the show.
If that a licker? That's badass.
It is.
You can see the full new poster over
at Resident Evil Netflix on Instagram.
And if you want, you can dive deeper
and find out more about Resident Evil
and the Umbrella Corporation head to
Umbrella is Joker
how very misleading you are.
Come on this is a Family Friendly
Corporation.
OK, this is our last big reveal of the day
before this
and you're on your way Jacob.
You can take this one.
Absolutely.
Jay Stoobs,
we all know you love the first German
original series Dark as much as we did.
The creators of the incredible mind
bending
German sci fi drama are coming back
with an even wilder series.
We're talking about 1899,
a brand new thriller that follows
the mysterious circumstances around the
voyage of an immigrant ship from Europe.
To New York.
The passengers, all of different
backgrounds and nationalities are united
by their hopes and dreams
for a new century and their future abroad.
All this makes us so sad
because they discover a second ship adrift
on the open sea
that have gone missing for months,
and their journey
takes an unexpected turn.
Oh, why. You never
take the detour.
You never take the detour.
They should of
just went straight to the coast.
It just-you hate to see
it happen to good people.
Let's take a look. Hi, I'm Emily Beecham.
I play more from 1899
and I can't wait for you to enjoy this
show.
I am Maura Franklin.
Today is October 19th.
1899 Why do you think they are all here?
All running away from something.
Why else would someone do so much
different
wake up.
People are oblivious to reality.
And see what they want to see.
And they have to.
Shift perspective
to see the full scope of things and.
Hi. My name is Janjte.
I'm the showrunner and head
writer of Dark.
I'm Baran bo Odar.
I'm the showrunner, director
and executive producer of 1899.
Dark was not about action at all,
but this is really an action show
with a lot of violence,
beating, running, screaming,
and someone
at Netflix
told us about the volume technology.
To be honest, after three seasons of Dark,
we were a bit tired of doing it
in a very traditional way.
Netflix was super helpful
from the beginning because they said
this might be the future and could be
really interesting for your project.
How would you describe.
The volume to somebody who knows
nothing about it?
I tried to describe it to my son
that I just said, Oh,
oh, it's like the biggest TV
he'll ever see,
and we just act in front of it.
It looks real, it really looks real.
And that,
of course, it's a huge help for us.
So we don't have to travel to
to the desert nor to the North Pole,
nor to the glaciers and stuff.
You can change that within a minute.
It would be a totally different experience
if we're doing this on green screen,
it just illuminates
like literally everything.
You see the whole landscape
in front of you and the lighting.
And so you're really looking at the sea.
It's a lot of prep work.
It is a lot of frustration
at the beginning because it is literally
a new way of filmmaking.
We get to be pioneers.
We get to work on things
we have no idea about.
I think it's going to be exciting to watch
if the audience actually loves this
new puzzle too, as they like the dark
and if they will figure it out.
But this show is actually really a box.
So what's up with that
black goo and the girl getting yanked back
and the bodies everywhere
I thought this was about a ship.
If you like, mysterious period pieces,
be sure to check out 1899.
All right, geeked week.
That's it for us. We covered so much.
We laughed, we scream
we cried with you all about these
amazing upcoming Netflix series,
both new and returning.
But up next, we'll be chatting
with the cast of The Sandman.
Yes, The Sandman and yes, you're
finally finding out when it's coming.
And Felicia Day sits down
with the cast of the Umbrella Academy
for an exclusive
sneak peek at season three.
We haven't even begun
to scratch the surface
of all the incredible content to come.
Stay right here on Geeked Week.